Apple's Flagship 2024 iPad Pro is coming
in two short months and it's causing a
lot of controversy right now because of
the very high price tag apparently the
11-in new model is going to start at
$1,500 yes $700 more than the current
11in iPad Pro so in this video I'm going
to be talking about three different
things number one is the features that
we're expecting in this new iPad Pro
number two is how Apple could possibly
justify a starting price that high and
number three is why I think you are
going to want to buy one starting off
with number one we already know quite a
few features that have been leaked and
rumored about this new iPad Pro the main
one is the new displays first of all
there's going to be two sizes there's
going to be the 11in and the 13 in which
that one will be just slightly bigger so
I think the bezels on the screen itself
are going going to be shrunk down just a
little bit but the big upgrade this year
is going to be the actual display
technology where this iPad is going to
be the first one ever to have an OLED
display just like all the competition
like Samsung's been using OLED for many
years while Apple hasn't mainly because
OLED displays cannot get bright enough
and apple even chose mini LED on our
current iPad Pros for the 12.9 in model
because it reaches a very high 1,000
nits of brightness for HDR but for this
year's brand new model apple is doing
something completely new they're going
to be giving it a new hybrid OLED panel
and not just one but dual stacked OLED
panels in tandem so one on top of each
other and the main point here is to
actually double the brightness to match
the same 1,000 nits which has previously
been impossible for old OLED display so
apple is essentially taking on all the
benefits of OLED like the contrast all
the colors the black levels that are
pure black because the areas that are
black actually have the pixels turned
off completely so zero light so you get
perfect contrast and they're also going
to fix that Halo glowing effect that you
have on the mini LED display right now
on the iPad Pros where in the dark you
can see kind of the glow around the
local dimming zones which is honestly so
annoying especially on my personal
MacBook Pro at home like watching the
movie Dune just tons of weird glow
everywhere that's not going to happen on
this iPad Pro because it's going to be
fixed and it's also going to be double
the brightness of what you can get with
a standard OLED display so it's
essentially going to be the best tablet
display ever made and that's why it
might be more expensive because that
panel is going to be pretty pretty
expensive now on top of that there were
some rumors that we might be getting
getting a landscape oriented camera like
we have on the iPad 10 and the reason
they were able to do that is because
they don't have the apple pencil to
wireless charging right above that
camera so they're able to fit in inside
the internals in the bezel that camera
set up with all the sensors now the iPad
Pro does not have that because of the
apple pencil charger so one thing they
could do is potentially bring down the
camera ceras a little bit lower into the
display with a dynamic Island like we
have on the current iPhones and still
keep the apple pencil charger right
above it that's one way they could fix
it I know it might be weird with the
dynamic Island but they could be pushing
that technology in that way and the one
feature that we're still a little bit
iffy about is Max safe wireless charging
on the back of the iPad Pro I'm not
exactly sure how we can expect Apple to
make this happen if they do it might be
with some sort of a glass back but one
thing we do know is that apple is
redesigning the entire chassis so they
might as well try to fit that in
especially since we did see some leaks
and rumors about industry sources and
suppliers of Apple's Mac safe magnets
actually discussing the iPad Pro so
there's a hint right there and now let's
get into the second topic for discussion
which is the insane price tag
$1,500 for the 11in model 700 bucks more
than the current price and apparently
1,800 for the 13-in iPad Pro that is
such a massive jump in price because
right now we're actually recommending
the lower priced iPads because even $800
even $1,100 is too expensive for a lot
of people so we're recommending let's
say the iPad Mini the iPad 10 maybe even
the iPad Air $800 is a lot of money and
to think that Apple's going to almost
double the price is just insane so here
is what I think apple is cooking up
behind closed doors what if apple is
actually going to give us two new iPad
models the 11-in iPad Pro and the 11-in
iPad Ultra yes what if the ultra model
comes with more upgrades at that higher
$1,500 price while the 11-in iPad Pro
might come in at let's say $11,000 so
$200 more expensive but with a lot of
new features now of course the ultra is
going to come with exclusive features so
maybe the whole Mac safe might be
limited to that or maybe the Dual panel
OLED might be limited to the ultra or
some of the other features that'll be
exclusive to make it worth the price
they might even give us the M3 Pro chip
which might not happen because that chip
gets very hot and it might be way too
hot for a fanless chassis like the iPad
but who knows the point is they might
have two tiers iPad Pro and iPad Ultra
but even then a lot of people are going
to complain and say well wait a minute
who cares if it has all of this awesome
Hardware it's still limited by iPad OS
you have all this great performance but
the apps are just not as good as what
you can get on the Mac which is why a
lot of people pay way way more money
3,000 $4,000 $5,000 for MacBook Pros or
desktop Macs because they have so many
different apps and software that can
take advantage and do professional
workflows well that actually brings us
into number three which is my idea of
why you might actually really want to
buy this new $1,500 iPad Ultra what if
for the first time ever Apple allows you
to get the full version of Mac OS yes
desktop Mac OS for that exclusive iPad
Ultra model for the $1,500 price but
wait a minute that's probably not all
you're going to spend because I have a
feeling that if they give Mac OS to
these high-end iPad Pros they're likely
going to require the magic keyboard
which there are rumors of them making a
second generation version that's going
to be even better and look more like a
MacBook Pro
with actual aluminum on the bottom case
which means they could actually put in a
much better trackpad the force touch
trackpad like we have on the MacBook
Pros they could do that on the new magic
keyboard so who knows it might be around
$400 plus dollar so all in all you might
be spending 2,000 bucks on the 11in iPad
Ultra with Mac OS support that requires
that magic keyboard but you're basically
getting a full MacBook Pro Pro
replacement that actually has a
touchcreen yes none of the MacBook Pros
right now have touch screens but that
new iPad Ultra will have a touchcreen
with Mac OS support if it comes to that
and I know myself I was going against
this for so many years because to me it
makes sense for Apple to sell you both a
MacBook Pro and an iPad at the same time
they'd rather make double the money
instead of just selling you one product
that can do it all but if they can raise
the price High Enough to where you're
spending at least $2,000 to get the
setup it's basically just a replacement
for getting one of the MacBooks and keep
in mind the MacBooks are pretty cheap
you could get a MacBook Air for $1,000
so hey they'd be happy to make you spend
2,000 for this new system and then of
course the iPad Pro already has
Thunderbolt for connecting accessories
storage ssds whatever you want to make
it feel like a real computer it just
needs that software especially where you
can go into Safari download some more
apps that aren't exactly on the App
Store that is going to be killer and
that is how I think Apple could easily
justify a price tag of
$1,500 plus more if you want the magic
keyboard case and I think a lot of
people are actually going to buy it and
you are probably going to want it as
well so hopefully you enjoy this video
and if you did you can subscribe above
and check out one of those two videos
right over there thanks for watching and
we'll see you in the next
[Music]
video